so we have here f of x being equal to
the natural log of the square root of x
and what we want to do in this video is
find the derivative of f
and the corr the the key here is to
recognize that f it can actually be
viewed as the composition of two
functions and we can diagram that out
what's going on here well if you input
an x into our function f what's the
first thing that you do well you take
the square root of it so if you
if we start off with some x
you input it the first thing that you do
is you take the square root of it so
you are going to take the square root of
the input to produce the square root of
x and then what do you do well you take
the square root and then you take the
natural log of that
and so then you take the natural log of
that so you could be you could view that
as inputting it to another function that
takes the natural log of whatever is
inputted in i'm making these little
squares to show what you do with the
input and then what do you produce
well you produce the natural log of the
square root of x
natural log of the square root of x
which is equal to f of x so you could
view f of x
as this entire
as this entire
set or this entire
i guess you could say this combination
of functions right over there that is f
of x which is essentially a composition
of two functions you're inputting into
one function then taking that output and
putting it into another so you could
have a function u here which takes the
square root of whatever its input in is
so u of x is equal to the square root of
x
and then you take another and then you
take that output and input into another
function that we could call v and what
does v do well it takes the natural log
of whatever the input is in this case in
in the case of f or in the case of where
how i've just diagrammed it v is taking
the natural log the input happens to be
square root of x so it outputs the
natural log of the square root of x if
we wanted to write v with x as an input
we would just say well that's just the
natural log that is just the natural log
of x and as you can see here f of x and
i color coded it ahead of time is equal
to
f of x
is equal to the natural log of the
square root of x so that is v of the
square root of x or v of u of x
so it is a composition which tells you
that okay if i'm trying to find the
derivative here the chain rule is going
to be very very very very useful and the
chain rule tells us that f prime of x
is going to be equal to
the derivative of you can view it as the
outside function with respect to this
inside function so it's going to be v
prime of u of x
v prime of u of x
times the derivative of this inside
function with respect to x so that's
just u prime
u prime of x
so how do we evaluate these things
well we know how to take the derivative
of u of x and v of x
u prime of x here is going to be equal
to
well remember square root of x is just
the same thing as x to the one-half
power so we can use the power rule bring
the one-half out front so it becomes
one-half x to the and then take off one
out of that exponent so that's one-half
minus one is negative 1 half power
and what is v
of x sorry what is v prime of x
well the derivative of the natural log
of x is 1 over x we show that in other
videos
and so we now know what u prime of x is
what is we know what v prime of x is but
what is v prime of u of x
well v
prime of u of x wherever we see the x we
replace it let me write that a little
bit neater we replace that with a u of x
so v prime of u of x is going to be
equal to
is going to be equal to 1 over u of x
1 over
u of x which is equal to
which is equal to 1 over u of x is just
the square root of x
1 over
the square root of x
so
this thing right over here we have
figured out is 1 over the square root of
x
and
this thing u prime of x we figured out
is one half times x to the negative one
half and x to the negative one half i
could rewrite that as one half times one
over
x to the one half which is the same
thing as one half times one over the
square root of x or i could write that
as one over two square roots of x
so what is this thing going to be
well this is going to be equal to
in green v prime of u of x is 1 over
the square root of x
times times u prime of x is 1 over 2
times the square root of x now what is
this going to be equal to
well this is going to be equal to this
is just algebra at this point 1 over we
have our 2 and square root of x times
square root of x is just x so it just
simplifies to 1 over 2x
so hopefully this made sense and i
intentionally diagrammed it out so you
start to get that muscle in your brain
going of recognizing the composite
functions and then making a little bit
more sense of some of these expressions
of the chain rule that you might see in
your calculus class or in your calculus
textbook but as you get more practice
you'll start to you'll be able to do it
essentially without having to write out
all of this you'll say okay look i have
a composition this is the natural log of
the square root of x this is v of
u of x so what i want to do is i want to
take the derivative of this outside
function with respect to this inside
function so the derivative of natural
log of something with respect to that
something is 1 over that something so it
is 1 over that something the derivative
of natural log of something with respect
to that something is 1 over that
something so that's what we just did
here one way to think about it what was
natural what would natural log of x be
well that would be 1 over x but it's not
natural log of x it's 1 over square root
of x so it's going to be 1 over the
square root of x so you take the
derivative of the outside function with
respect to the inside one
and then you multiply that times just
the derivative of the inside function
with respect to x and we are done